and we have some breaking news just
coming in germany's conservative bloc
has agreed on armin lushet
to be its candidate for uh chancellor in
the country's upcoming elections
this fall his rival marco zulu conceded
the race just moments ago so let's go
straight to our
chief political correspondent chief
political editor rather michelle
for more on this uh big news there the
cdu finally
seems to have an undisputed candidate
candidate to succeed angela merkel is
that true
yes although undisputed uh it was
a bumpy road to this uh we just heard
marco soda the leader
of the much smaller csu sister party of
angela merkel's mighty conservative cdu
party
essentially concede defeat in a
competition
that really wasn't formal it was a very
informal bruising competition
where marcus zurda questioned whether
amin lashed should really be in pole
position to be
on the ticket pointing towards those
opinion polls uh here in germany which
have seen marco suda continuously in the
lead for some time
amen lashed will have quite a bit of
bouncing back to do
there was also a late night session
which even saw
one of angela merkel's closest allies
german economics minister altmayer back
soda and then do
a turnaround today so a lot of bruising
stuff a lot of
noise to come to the point which was
seen as a given that amin lashed the cdu
leader
is also on the ticket to become
chancellor candidate
well stay with us we'll come back to you
in a moment let's first have a look
at the cdu candidate in more detail
merkel ally carnival king committed
european
there are many faces to armen lashed but
does he have what it takes to be german
chancellor
according to lashit his position as
state premier of north rhine westphalia
germany's most populous state and his
victory to get there
is proof enough his election as cdu
party leader in january 2021
put him in prime position to run for
chancellor backed by the cdu's top brass
lashit says he aspires to make the 2020s
a decade of modernisation for germany
my canada tour my candidacy
my understanding of the german
chancellorship is a european one
the whole of europe is watching to see
how germany finds
new leadership at this time and we need
multilateral solutions for every problem
that is a global one
finding global house masses
the 60 year old reinlander's commitment
to europe has been years in the making
born in the western city of arkhan close
to the dutch and belgium borders
lashit is a former member of the
european parliament and fluent in french
his family even claims to be descendants
of charlemagne
founder of the holy roman empire across
the atlantic he wants to push for more
cooperation with the us
particularly on climate and trade policy
some of his comments on russia syria and
china however have raised eyebrows
in just one instance in 2014 his
warnings against demonizing russian
president vladimir putin
for the annexation of crimea earned him
the title of husland verstaya from some
critics a derogatory term for people who
take a soft stance on putin's russia
as leader of the german federal state
with the closest ties to china
concerns about protecting german export
industries
have also led to his more lenient stance
towards the world's second largest
economy
drawing allegations that he puts
business interests above
security for the large part however his
politics are moderate
center-ground and mercolesque making him
a long-time ally to the chancellor
that was until the covert 19 pandemic
despite merkel's repeated calls for
unity from state leaders
lashit has often opted for a looser
interpretation of measures to tackle the
pandemic
but poor crisis communication has seen
his popularity plummet with voters
not only in his home state stability and
continuity used to be the key to success
among german voters
now it seems lashit will need to be more
than just the greenland miracle
if he wants to fill her shoes in the
chancellery
all right let's go back to our chief
political term
big shoes to fill nonetheless following
up
behind angela merkel is he up to it
well he was very often asked in his time
whether he's up to it and he always came
through he always came on top he's one
of those people who are underestimated
continuously
as he just has been by his contender
marco
souda of bavaria who says he will now
stand
side by side with armin lashed now
despite the fact that he is now
officially the chancellor candidate as
official as you can get
because there's no such formalized
process he
did see a lot of doubts being sowed over
particularly over those past days and
those debates that were had won't be
forgotten they will continue
within his own conservative cduc csu
camp
so it will be even more of an uphill
struggle for him
from now to get rid of those question
marks over his name and over the chances
of success
under someone on the ticket who is seen
as a continuation
of medical politics who was seen as a
male mackerel
which may simply not fly as a new
departure for germany
and for her conservative party
how damaging was this very public
bickering that we've
seen are voters unhappy with the party
briefly if you can
well it was certainly a very damaging
amongst the
party grassroots here interestingly the
cdu didn't suffer more in the polls it
had recently over
the poor performance on vaccinations in
this pandemic response
so um the big question now will be what
will come
in those coming weeks whether
almond lashit will be responsible for an
upward or downward trend
uh currently the cdu stands in the upper
20s in the polls it has been higher in
the past and he now has to at least
defend this
our chief political editor michael
o'keefner thank you very much michaela